you most likely know about the awful
human experiments conducted by the nazis
with associated names like arbit heim
and joseph mengele but the german's
partners in cram the japanese who
sometimes committed even more horrifying
war crimes are often times left out
therefore i'm going to tell you a little
story about the unit 731
this entire story starts in 1930 japan
where the japanese war ministry is
pressured by multiple scientists to
create the japanese biological weapons
research program
the scientists saw the effective german
use of biological weapons in world war 1
and wanted to replicate and improve upon
the idea of biological weapons one of
the main scientists pushing for the
creation of biological weapons research
program was shiro ichi he got his wish
in 1932 following the japanese invasion
of manchuria shiroishi along with sado
araki became the heads of army epidemic
prevention research laboratory within
this division shear organized a secret
unit called the toco unit for various
biological
and chemical experiments within
manchuria manchuria was perfect for such
a unit
as human test subjects could be plucked
from the streets like
rats togo unit started its first
experiments in a prison camp called
zongma fortress zoma fortress was
constructed by chinese local conscripts
which were for all intensive purposes is
like slaves who were forced to wear
blinders so they wouldn't see what they
were building
the builders that were used to construct
the more sensitive areas of the compound
the medical and surgical laboratories
were executed to ensure absolute secrecy
after it was finished the fortress could
hold up to 1 000 prisoners but only held
around 500 prisoners at any given
moment prisoners included common
criminals captured bandits anti-japanese
partisans political prisoners and people
rounded up on fake charges by the
campaign aka japanese gestapo the
prisoners were always well fed because
the researchers needed healthy subjects
for their
experiments two human experiments
conducted a zongma fortress
included but were not limited to
draining of blood over several days with
well-kept records on the deteriorating
physical condition
nutrient and water deprivation again
with well-kept records on deteriorating
physical condition
injection of various types of microbes
bacteria and viruses
and all of this while conducting
experimental and research surgeries on
the subjects oftentimes with no
anesthesia the prisoners who were able
to survive the experiments were killed
again to ensure absolute secrecy due to
this the average life expectancy of a
prisoner in zogman fortress was about a
month
however in 1934 some of the prisoners
managed to escape and spread the word
about the horrifying experiments done in
the zongma fortress
now with all eyes on the fortress she
couldn't afford to continue with the
experiments and eventually close down
the zoma fortress however the
experiments that the ishii and the toga
unit conducted in the zogma fortress
were sadly just a precursor to what's to
come with the zongwa fortress closed
ishii needed a new place where to
conduct his experiments
and in 1936 authorized by the imperial
decree and with new funds
ishii constructed the unit 731 the
subjects of unit 731 were selected the
same way like the subjects in the zongma
fortress
however with one key difference unit 731
scientists
demanded a wide variety of people and
therefore the subjects in the unit
range from infants to pregnant women
from chinese to russian and even some
captured ally soldiers
the experiments conducted in unit 731
expanded upon the ones conducted in the
zongmao fortress i'm not going to go
into a lot of detail here since i still
want you to sleep tonight however a
large part of all the experiments
conducted in unit 731
involved these sections if you don't
know what that is
it looks like this one done to a rat
these sections were apparently an
integral part of the research as they
helped the scientists understand how the
bacteria virus or chemical weapons
affected different parts of the body
these vivid sections were done without
anesthesia while the subjects were alive
as the scientists feared
their anesthetics and their composition
process might hamper the results
other kinds of experiments included
frostbite testing weapon testing
syphilis testing with subjects being
forced to have sex with each other or be
killed
rape and forced pregnancy by japanese
scientists and radiation testing just to
name a few
all of the subjects that survived any of
the testing died during the
sections afterwards sadly unit 731 even
though being the largest human
experimentation laboratory wasn't the
only one in imperial japan
there was unit 100 conducting
experiments with animal diseases
on humans and many other smaller units
which to this day
we don't know much about not to even
mention the participation of various
japanese universities and some of the
research
all of these tests resulted in
large-scale experiments
or more like genocides conducted on the
chinese populations these included but
were not limited to spread of cholera
bubonic plague anthrax tularamia adakta
one such experiment
done with the cholera and anthrax which
were spread through clothing
contaminated supplies and airdrops
killed over 400 000 chinese civilians
however the attempts by ishii to use
these biological weapons in the pacific
war were shut down by the japanese
military as they saw no major
applications towards the end of the war
experimentation slowed down as the
japanese empire had bigger problems to
worry about
in 1945 with the red army advancing into
china where majority of the experimental
units were located
the entire epidemic prevention and water
purification department shut down and
all the scientists returned to japan
after blowing up and destroying all the
evidence of all the units
in japan the scientists involved with
the experimentations were given
potassium cyanide vials and were told to
take the secret to the grave if
interrogated however this didn't happen
and after japan was occupied most of the
scientists exchanged information from
experiments for immunity the soviets
weren't too hasty to convict the
japanese scientists as they wanted the
information but more importantly had
thousands of japanese pows which they
didn't want to release and also didn't
want to draw attention to them by
putting japanese scientists on trial
of course the soviets denied any of this
americans on the other hand wanted to
develop biological weapons of their own
due to you know therefore they needed
all the information they could get from
the japanese scientists and that is why
almost no japanese scientists were put
on trial for their actions and human
experimentations
of course the us denied any of this even
the main instigator of the entire
project hiroishi was never put on trial
and was given immunity by the americans
in the end the history is always written
by the victors and that is why the
japanese war crimes aren't talked about
as much
as the american and soviet governments
tried to hide the information from the
public for their own benefits
you